&gt;&gt; So Matt, you're telling me that we have over 3 billion letters or nucleotides
in each one of our cells. But how does this DNA actually make who we are?
&gt;&gt; Right, it's a very good question and it's kind of hard to conceive that so much
information can fit in such a small space. It's important to recognize that we
call the total amount of genetic information your genome. And within
everybody's genome, there are segments called genes that code for something,
typically proteins.
&gt;&gt; Well, what do you mean by coding for proteins though?
&gt;&gt; Proteins are a large part of what makes up who we are. So the physical stuff
like the, the flesh, the skin, the hair. When you look at another person, who
they are is coded for by these genes, which are segments of their genome. Now,
genes only make up 2% of the human genome.
&gt;&gt; Well, then what's going on with the other 98%?
&gt;&gt; Well, that other 98% is still very important. Now, a large part of it we know
regulates that 2%. It determines how those genes are turned on and off at the
right time, and the right place. And there is also another bit of that 98% that
we don't know what's going on yet. And we're actively researching that and
learning more every day.